hi this is Kelly monmon with McLarty
associates and we just moderated our
panel that asked the question how come
Latin America strike the right balance
in proposing energy solutions while
addressing climate change and form
really did an excellent job of putting
together the various players that need
to be answering that question frankly
working together in order to answer that
question from regulators and government
to experts on the nuclear industry
fossil fuels when technology so we were
able to get into a bit of a good
discussion on conservation and energy
efficiency as well and at the end of the
day our conclusion was primarily that
what you need to do and what for everman
seem to do is to be sure that all of
these players work together collaborate
and come up with consensus politically
viable economically sustainable
solutions to being sure that the energy
mix in Egypt countries in Latin America
is really able to achieve both the
climate change holes but also
competitiveness goals and while still
ensuring energy security on the great
American basis so in excellent
discussion and
ok